so far for our hipster shop app we have
sto setup with our kubernetes engine
cluster and we've set up some
intelligent traffic management using SEO
but how do I monitor each SEO component
well like many of our services on Google
cloud staff driver can integrate and
monitor your kubernetes cluster and sto
components ah stackdriver another
hipster favorite yes
let's jump into it and I'll show you how
it all works
stackdriver combined with sto reduces
the complexity of managing micro service
deployments by providing a uniform way
to log monitor and trace your
application once these geo service is
set up we can first visit the metrics
Explorer from here type sto in the find
resource type and metrics section
numerous additional metrics from the sto
service are now available let's look at
client request count this metric shows
the number of client requests sent by
the service on the right side we see a
graph with numerous service records and
details when we mouse over them on the
left side we have filters to narrow down
or combine data elements on the graph
let's get a mean of the client request
count for all the services how that
looks better not only are we able to
view individual metrics but with issue
oh we are able to see how our services
are connected from a top down view let's
visit the topology section if we mouse
over the front-end we are able to see
specific services it communicates with
depending on the data made available
with the service things like latency it
may also appear this becomes especially
useful for large-scale projects with
hundreds of connected services
additionally if you are curious about
how a particular service performs you
can drill into each section from the
overview here we can see the service
level specifics including the individual
request count we looked at earlier under
the service section it gives us yet
another view of sto data this time with
a per service detailed view of all the
metrics date and time filters are
provided at the top of the page to
narrow down the metrics to exactly when
you want to see your data just below
that there are three tabs s loz metrics
and Diagnostics the SL o--'s tab
provides things like compliance
indicators and errors to help an assess
if a specific service is within SLO the
next tab metrics provides the same
details we saw in the drill down with
the topology view
the third tab Diagnostics provides us
with service level trace data errors and
logs here we are able to select filters
and see which specific functions within
the service are slowing things down on
the top we can see the parameters and
values called within the specific traces
on the right-hand column
triggered events from service level
policies appear each of these sections
links to respective stackdriver page for
further details here we can see the
expanded traceless along with timing
data to get a better overview
data doesn't always look perfect to help
test configurations we can use the ML
files such as this to mess up those
pretty graphs and see how our
application handles false by calling
this file using coop CTL we are able to
help 50% of the traffic in our shipping
service by giving a 505 error more
details on fault injection with Sto are
linked below
seeing that service graph really adds
clarity to how each is do component
interacts I love it yes doctor ever
makes it really easy to monitor trace
and debug your sto applications well I
can't wait to see what else you have in
store to integrate with an SCO enabled
kubernetes cluster don't forget to Like
comment and subscribe to stay up to date
with our next episode and if you'd like
to get in contact with us click on the
link in the description
[Music]